tomorrow's my mom's birthday no how did
you remember I don't remember none of my
family's birthdays so we're doing an mi
the [ __ ]
yeah yeah Nikki was by the [ __ ] for
refusing to sleep on us on the sofa even
though my wife is pregnant yes really
Gio pregnant and it's very painful but
you in your [ __ ] place okay go
wait we both suffer for no reason or did
he get in trouble no he's no are you
ready he made her asleep so are you
ready to get put in your place oh no I
don't want to get put in my place
tonight to get back and we said to solve
it you you're getting put anybody's deal
with it is it for snoring no okay
my wife is seven months pregnant and
yesterday we had a fight is not the
point
she sold my ps4 without asking me okay
because people are gonna ask that's
pretty yes I will say ps4 is about to be
phased out everyone kind of knows that
they really did that betting for she
might be surprising on what that ps5 she
might be not money no no though there
was only one good game for ps4 it's
called spider-man nobody cared although
than that okay well what if they have a
youtube channel and that's a prank that
could be I didn't factor that I think it
all depends on what the outcome is yeah
so after this happens she then tells me
to sleep on the sofa when she goes to
bed I've had a bad back since a car
accident in my late teens is that okay
yes four and then she goes off and tells
him to sit on victory pond the couch
[Laughter]
[Music]
does he have a job maybe like she's
working and then yeah well she's being
the bills he can't just go by you know
ps4 or something like especially when
they just got the money for selling up
his boy right so he's had it back back
since he got a car so that ends late
teens and the sofa makes it ten times
worse for the record he got hit by a
drunk driver it's not his fault
damn I said no if she had a problem with
that she could sleep on the sofa
what's worse now pregnancy or a broken
back right he sounds like a teen
my mom stole my ps4 he's like it's not
relevant just in case you're wondering
she sold my ps4 without asking there's a
high demand for a switch and there's not
a high - may ever be it's not talking
about this for an Amazon right now
Nelson switches stuff no I'm talking
about the fact that if he sold it
there's no way to get your Island back
yeah that's true absolutely no way that
he sold hours of your life away that's
true 160 hours so far the point is why
is she selling his things without asking
ya gotta be something going on there but
the way he's reacting to it like I'm
also like well what is the reason
because there's something missing it's
not just I sold your ps4 he wrote his
own story she probably sold his ps4 and
let's face it it probably had a copy of
the sound hell's demo and like that's
worth a lot more money and so he she
sold her way under market value because
one time Steve had a huge wire boxing he
never used any of the wires for at all
and then I complained about it
constantly on sewing one day he threw up
the wires he never missed the wires ever
he never missed the wire box it's not
sure I just have bought wires okay just
like but that's what I said usually need
the wires then you could buy a new one
they're not actually useful
he was probably playing video games
right and there's only him up into the
the naked challenge yeah well he was
probably playing way too much and not
helping around that only happens to the
straightest that's why I needed know cuz
I think that's too petty like that's the
wife isn't the wrong if he's not helping
it's also hormonal now because that's
too petty but if it was something like
like he isn't paying for things and they
don't have money to pay rent and he's
like I don't [ __ ] care
good guesses but let me hit you with my
favorite paragraph in this whole [ __ ] oh
here we go
she's like yo yo you're sleeping on a
sofa he said no and a share of casino
simp yeah and she had a problem that she
could sleep on the sofa oh she said she
can't because she's pregnant yeah it's
painful I said too bad then and got in
bed and tried to sleep
that's my favorite seven hopeless maybe
today period too bad too bad I'm
sleeping with you climb to the bed Reza
sleep
she then started yelling at me that it's
unfair to force her to sleep with me
when she has nowhere else to go
neither of us slept at all last night
which is he the [ __ ] I mean work out
your problem before going to bed then
that's what I would say yeah we're both
pregnant leader irrational point though
they both just it don't seem like either
of them should sleep on the couch if
it's if he has a real condition with his
back and it's horrible for him and he's
gonna be in pain for like a week that
makes sense
do they have a twin size bed or
something right they're like touching
they're like cause like if you if you
went to bed and I was mad at you I'd
just be like I don't [ __ ] care and
one a bit sleepy
maybe she spoons him and his back is
like so [ __ ] up that Arab summit fits
that's how the twin bed works I never
thought of it like a puzzle piece I
don't know I think I don't know if
anyone's the [ __ ] in this story what
they both sound like [ __ ] to me yeah
because why would you sell something
that's not yours like that's [ __ ] up
for you to sell some once and he's lie
about something yes for ps4 only has one
good game maybe regardless let's just
have halo let's just say holy don't put
it this way let's assume she threw away
his toothbrush
you know without asking that's a high
offense so she was like no that was
disgusting it was disgusting and she was
buying one a new toothbrush but he's
still got upset in here though I'm gonna
way he brushes his teeth towards today
she throw away super much before he was
disgusting it was completely mad at you
did she buy the 2004 oh I know she did
right now yeah I threw it away first so
gonna surprise him big shocker
yeah I was surprised because there's no
toothbrush yeah what was it was
inefficient anyway wasn't cleaning your
teeth because it was cartridge got it
down to the [ __ ] bone nah yeah yeah
anyways we're talking about that my
mother hates you probably how their
argument went down too
she's suicidal she was she when I went
into bed damn I would hate to be in that
relation that's ex I was whoa who's the
type of person that goes on reddit and
types these things sometimes creative
writers and sometimes real people who
want this [ __ ] the way he's so defensive
about the accident I don't know it just
comes off really like over defensive
yeah so it's me not aq sighs like I said
cuz he knows that people can be like you
your backs perked up I don't believe you
bow on the details all right how it's a
drunk driver and like just say you got
it cracks it like what know but he's
reddit scary really wants I know renters
are gonna ask me about this [ __ ] it's
like how people have to edit before they
say something cuz the commentary yes I
get that
what are you just if you're gonna say
the stories are irrelevant don't go like
hey too long didn't read it at the end
and you're like that's all I needed to
read man this [ __ ] sucks yeah but no but
they're the very aware people who are
like I know Ritter's are gonna beat me
up because I wrote three paragraphs the
TLDR is at the bottom and then TL DR
sometimes is like 18 sentences but what
steal the organ oh like we're saying
that they're both [ __ ] personally I
don't feel like he's an [ __ ] cuz he's
just like none of us should sleep on the
couch I get that honey who had to go lay
in bed he's like if you don't like it
I'm gonna be here anyway what's funny I
don't have any context yeah what's funny
is that she didn't need the bed to
herself because she's pregnant until the
night they got into an argument
ya know get wasn't because she's
practice exactly what I'm saying she
didn't need it he's kind of selfish on
her because she's pregnant she just
needs it because they're in an argument
yeah she just doesn't want to sleep on
the sofa go he's that of course she
doesn't want he's just saying if you
don't want to sleep with ya then you
take the new ticket but if you didn't
have a medical condition
wouldn't that be fine to ask of him yeah
yeah but I mean if you know yet
it's kind of weird fight he's kind of
weird too I guess I mean I wouldn't make
someone else do something cuz I'm mad I
would just be body I would he didn't
highlight her side didn't say her side
of like why they're in a why is she mad
at him why did she sell the beer that's
one thing he said to the whole [ __ ]
thing why would he say that when he's at
fault he has nothing to say but well he
doesn't know that he's at fault for a
long time I thought you made up this
whole story part
go ahead brother I thought you made up
the ps4 apart for the longest time you
know like this be the last thing really
long no swears oh that's what they
fought over oh my god they sound like
[ __ ] 16 year old yeah I mean I guess
if I owned anything if she just sold it
I'd be like that's what's crazy the
argument came from a bunch of different
solutely yeah it was about like a money
he just didn't get it you like it it's
all about the ps4 and she's like no you
[ __ ]
Yeah right thing here is damn why is
y'all get married and even have a kid
together you crazy sons of [ __ ] or
get better couch that you guys are down
right because too much I sleep in the
other room like in my office we have a
trundle bed and then like it he snores
too loud and I can't sleep I just go
sleeping but you don't kick him off
right no but it's a nice it's a nice
mattress in there I make sure that like
everything's all good in there it's like
you should pull it out in a grid yeah
you're pulling it out and then when I
have to work in the mornings push you
back in and I'm already in my office
okay if I were having a girls sleepover
or like when they do like I always tell
them I guess I'm overly loud because
it's really [ __ ] bad I can wreck it
most nights I don't hear it because I
fall asleep first and I sleep I hear a
deep sleeper that earthquake I didn't
feel at all we had an earthquake this
past weekend oh you're so nervous about
it
I slept through the whole thing no idea
the whole house shifted for us and I was
like God he was like it was like a
missile hit our house and I wind check
of her immediately and she was even
stories we just heard that a little bit
and you can feel it but it wasn't like
any crazy thing yeah I don't know I
think the both
[Music]
you